so it kind of doesn't matter in that
case
whether it's on one side of the event
horizon or the other
am i right here brian i mean it's just
it's the it's the black hole
giving there's lots of ways to think
about it i mean in steven's paper
actually the 1974 one stephen stephen's
paper
not joey's paper not jimmy's paper but
stevie reno's paper okay
go on brian
[Music]
this is star talk cosmic queries edition
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist got with me chuck nice
hey neil
you're the man for cosmic queries you
know this i know this i hope i hope i'm
the man for something
people love hearing you mispronounce
their name
what can i say but i have to tell them
it's not on purpose and they don't they
don't believe it they think you're
better than that yeah and then you're
just messing with them well listen uh i
i appreciate your um raised expectations
and uh much like my parents you will
find that i will not meet those
expectations
every comedian says that about their
parents i'm sure oh god yes uh so uh
chuck you know we we had brian cox on
for cosmic queries and people went ape
over that super popular and he's he was
on tour in across the united states and
we were catching him on the day of his
last presentation brian cox coming back
to star talk how you doing brian
very well thank you and i i well chuck
can't pronounce my name wrong kenny that
that surely i've got the shoulder
it's still true
however
breon could happen
so let me remind people uh brian cox is
a is a theoretical particle physicist uh
in the uk
and he has a huge public following
having hosted many programs on bbc i i
forgot all the names because they blend
together is it like the solar system
universe
yeah the wonders of the solar system
winners of the universe and then as you
know then you run out of titles so then
we did the universe yeah and the planet
yeah and then we've run around now
maybe you should the next show should
just be like look it's me brian that's
all
come on you already know it's me
right right but i think between brian in
the physical universe and
uh who's everyone's favorite grand
grandpa uh
in the uk who hosts the shows
excuse me sir
oh that's right
indeed
indeed
as we look upon the frozen tundra
we see here the majestic popping
as it makes his way that happened
well that's good yeah yeah yeah yeah
everybody loves sir david attenborough
yeah so the two of you basically split
the the
the natural in the physical universe in
your in your public presentations of it
and it delights everyone but i happen to
have you on the show specifically for
your expertise in cosmology and in uh
relativity black holes big bang particle
physics and because this goes beyond
where i have
total control over
over what i know and so it's a lot hell
of a lot harder than capuchin monkeys
okay
just take that sir david
i don't know i i would say one of the
simplest things from the outside anyway
is a black hole right it's a very very
simple equation that describes it
whereas a monkey
no one will ever understand the monkey
black holes will throw their [ __ ] at you
[Laughter]
so chuck we've solicited questions from
our fan base and i'm delighted
uh about this overlap i mean brian and i
are just trying to bring the universe
down to earth to whoever is going to
listen and we'll just keep at it you
know until you know
for all our natural days so chuck give
it to me what do you have all right this
is jennifer
gildea or gilday
says hello dr cox dr tyson and dr lots
of laughs a question from my son colin
dr cox can you tell us more about the
theorized near destruction of earth and
what stopped this catastrophe just after
the big bang and could such a disaster
ever be caused by the higgs particle in
the future is there any way to detect
when or if such an event might occur now
there are many things mixed in that soup
right there
and many of them are way way apart
on a timeline but
there you have it wait let me tighten
that a little bit ahead
does the higgs boson uh
delighted that they got discovered at
cern and weren't you affiliated with
cern is that right you have a had an
appointment there
oh that was yes okay
yeah on the atlas experiment beautiful
beautiful and in fact there's a fun rap
video that describes the experiments
that are conducted at the this european
uh organization for nuclear research
and they describe the atlas experiment
in this rap video it's great um you've
seen it i'm sure brian it's
yeah it's magnificent i mean atlas just
to set this it's a huge camera basically
so it's one of the big the the big
detectors that observes these high
energy particle collisions that the
large hadron collider generates yeah
yeah and those are going to the question
there one way to think about it is that
it recreates the conditions that they
were present less than a billionth of a
second to the big bank
yeah so what's interesting is you can
create something even though we weren't
there for it
we can simulate it not even not just on
a computer but in real life which is so
so this higgs particle just give us like
a minute on the higgs particle in the
hicks field and then i'll put a back at
come through the back door into that
question
so the higgs particle it was theorized
actually back in the 1960s
it's a remarkable story because it was a
mathematical way of giving the
fundamental building blocks of the
universe mass so for the electron for
example
or the quarks that build up protons and
neutrons so at a fundamental level it
was difficult to write down mathematical
equations that describe nature as we see
it
without doing something rather clever
you can't just you can't just stick the
masses of the particles in and remember
the mass of the electron was it was
known since 1897 us and so we you know
we know this thing has math but it was
very difficult well but brian wait wait
just a moment
it's it's already
a big step to think to ourselves
that the mass comes from something right
isn't just the mass a property of matter
and now you're telling me
it's not a property of matter it's a
property of something else
handed to the matter
yeah it comes in in this picture which
as you said has now been shown to be
correct right because we discovered the
higgs particle and the the mass the most
fundamental level comes from the
interaction
of these things these particles with the
higgs field we call it a field so you
can imagine it as
something that fills the universe um
and uh so
i mean you get mass from all sorts of
things so so most of the mass actually
doesn't come from that most of it just
comes from it's really through
einstein's equation equals m c squared
so you can so energy equals mass and
mass equals energy and so so you can get
um mass by just things sticking together
so most of the mass of the protofund for
example is a which is one of the
building blocks of the nucleus comes
from the quark sticking together inside
the proton but at the most fundamental
level
yes the particles the building blocks
like quarks electrons have mess
and that comes from their interaction
with the higgs field
there's a kind of picture that people
use which is one of those where it's a
bit hand-wavy but it's a reasonable
picture it's it's you imagine pulling
something through you know what do you
call it treacle or syrup i never know
which way to call it in the u.s is it
treacle do you have that stuff yeah
maple syrup
that nobody has ever said would you care
for some pancakes in treacle
no idea what that is
everyone will know but i've been giving
these talks around the country in these
lectures
and i i know things like i know that the
um
an object the mass of the sun if you
squash it down to three kilometers in
radius then you get a black hole right
it's called the swatul radius
i don't really know it in miles and so i
have to multiply everything by 0.6 in my
head so i know how these dudes
all right don't take don't put blame on
us that came from your people your your
kindred souls of generations gone by and
then you try to confuse us later on
anyway
so so you if you if you have something
moved through maple syrup then um it it
sort of slows down it requires a a kind
of momentum-like quality to it and
that's one of the ways that people
describe the higgs field it's not the
best description but what we're saying
is that we now know that the most
fundamental level little points the
smallest particles we know of acquire
mass through an interaction with this
thing called higgs field and the point
is that it
it
it wasn't doing that very early on in
the history of the universe then as the
universe cooled down
uh just after the big bang
then higgs field kind of flips and in
this property of it's switched on
and that's and that's so things acquire
maps okay so is it possible uh could
something happen in the universe getting
back to the person's question could
something happen in the universe where
the higgs field malfunctions
and
the masses get confused and earth dies
somewhere in there there was the end of
the earth multiple times earth's gonna
die before that could possibly happen
right so you can relax you're going to
die
for 10 10 other reasons and there you go
jennifer take up smoking
yeah but even the solar system is going
to be a real mess right but before
because the sun's gonna as you know it's
gonna when it you know it's gonna start
swelling up in about a billion years
isn't it and then i think you know
ultimately a red giant bms i don't think
it will quite engulf you not quite but
it'll totally
uh
it'll totally torch us yes yes yeah i
mean half of the horizon will be the sun
when it rises just imagine that right
that's how big it will be in the sky wow
and
yeah yeah as the oceans come to a boil
and they evaporate and you lose the
atmosphere so yeah and we're putting it
at about six billion five to six billion
years but but but getting back to this
person's point okay is there a scenario
where the end of the earth would come
about
from for some particle physics reason
rather than from an astrophysical reason
i i
know is the the basic answer we the the
thing say about the higgs field so you
can picture it
as a kind of a valley imagine imagine a
high valley and then a lower valley so
if you had a little something rolling
around in a valley that was high up
and it rolled around in just the right
way it could flip flip out of that
valley roll down the hill into the lower
valley
and the higgs field
looks a bit like that and
so over the very very very very
immensely long times it is possible yes
that higgs field will change character
will change as it did in the early
universe as it did in the early universe
and that would change the laws of
physics that we see so it really would
um completely reconfigure um the
universe if that happened um but we so
chuck chuck chuck
reconfigure is euphemism for completely
destroyed
yes
right brian in the hood they said let me
reconfigure your face
and actually and it's interesting
actually the the the um so there's
another element to these predictions
which is called the top quark which is
the heaviest fundamental particle that
we've discovered
uh and and that the mess of that is is
intimately related to these sort of
predictions and and they are kind of on
the edge of stability but i just want to
reassure people by edge stability people
are talking about trillions of you if
you imagine the half-life of a
radioactive atom a nucleus right you
know the
uranium or something and it takes
billions of years to half of these
things to decay it's like that so you're
talking trillions of years
before you have a a chance that this
thing sort of reconfigures that's
basically the point so it's not
something that some people should worry
about which is why i say that you know
no that's not going to destroy the earth
because it's not going to happen on time
scales to that length what's interesting
to me if in trillions of years the
universe reconfigures it could
reconfigure to a whole other
combination of laws of physics right
yeah you're you're saying things like um
you're changing the mass of the electron
for example you might that the photon
particle light may not be massless if
you if you change the character of the
higgs field it could give light mass
rather than the so-called w and z bosons
which is to do with if you're a student
you'll know radioactive beta decay it's
a there's
light would have light would be making a
schlep then
across the schlep across the universe if
it wasn't massless
you know by time it get here be like
jesus i'm so tired
oh god
oh it's inconceivable i mean you don't
really you can't we can't conceive of
the universe with
massive where particles of light are
massive and electrons are different mass
i think you know
the the possibilities appear to be
endless i should say this is right at
the edge of our knowledge so we don't we
don't really know
but it's interesting but yes the point
is that basically we do have
theoretical scenarios where the higgs
field can can change and change
character and that would change the
things that we call the laws of physics
wow
and would have consequences vastly
greater than just the destruction of the
earth that's pretty cool oh yeah
yeah or rather the
the reconnaissance
i'm sorry people the earth is now going
to be a vacation spot
reconfigured for another dimension
rearrange the deck chairs
we got to take a quick break when we
come back yeah i know that went quickly
but we but we learned all about higgs
bosons and a little bit of the history
of it uh when we come back more with my
friend and colleague from across the
pond
brian cox so we'll be right back with
cosmic queries
we're back cosmic queries of course i
got chuck nice on this that's right and
uh and i have to call him a special
guest brian cox you know we don't get
him often a friend and colleague and
a physicist extraordinaire and and brian
it's just been a delight to have you on
this side of the the ocean and so thanks
for uh gracing us with your expertise
and your charm and and everything else
that gets people excited about the
universe now we just spent the whole
first of three segments talking about
destroying earth with the higgs boson
yeah
all right so brian my favorite an analog
for the higgs field did i tell you this
it's uh when i if i'm in la i refer to
uh the higgs field is like a party field
in los angeles
okay so you you go into a party
and
nobody knows who you are
and you have to get to the bar which is
at the other side of the huge room and
you could just walk there and get there
pretty quickly but beyonce enters
and people crowd around her and she can
only move much more slowly
to the bar so she has a much higher
party mass
than someone that nobody's ever heard of
in los angeles so is that that is that
an exact mathematical analog
it's a really good
that causes the mass
correct and it's different from your
molasses because
molasses probably has sort of the same
um
um uh formula for the force on it i mean
maybe that's also true for the higgs
boson i don't know but the the
uh was it the v squared uh resistance to
motion
you know like air resistance right so
but here it's it's in the party field
you're right it's they're one-on-one
interactions that completely define
everything about it and who gets to the
bar faster so beyonce never gets to the
bar right that's how that works and that
is
that is why based on my career i am
drunk
because you got to the bar real fast i
can't even get away from the bars like i
can't couldn't get to the bar fast
enough
who's that guy nobody knows nobody knows
so me give me another one what's the
next question you got for us uh elaine
brudeau says hey guys uh elaine here
from montreal canada uh great why do we
say that nothing can travel faster than
light
when the universe is expanding
faster than light and entangled
particles communicate with each other
faster than light and also when we say
that a black hole is so dense that even
light can't escape it well it makes it
sound as if there is actually light
inside the black hole trying to get out
but to me if a star gets spaghettified
and reduced to a stream of atoms while
entering the black hole there is no fire
in that light going on
only atoms am i right
so there brian
is to take the one which neil can
talk about as well let's say the the
easy bits first so
so um yes um in so so often we describe
space-time the this as the fabric of the
universe the style of brian green's
great book right the fabric of the
universe
and indeed light travels at the speed of
light
over that thing that surface that fabric
and nothing travel faster than it and
that's really built into the geometry
itself and it allows the universe to
respect cause and effects and all sorts
of things right so it's absolutely
fundamental
um and actually we should say going back
to the previous question it's massless
particles that travel at the speed of
light that light happens to be massless
because it doesn't interact with the
higgs field going back to the previous
thing so so light's not the special
thing it's actually things without mass
right um
but the expansion of the universe you
can picture you really can picture it
like a sheet it's often described as a
rubber sheet just a stretchy kind of
sheet
and you and it stretches and so the
distance between two points increases
over time
if you just stretch any old thing at a
constant rate
but it's very big
then if you have very distant points
then they recede from each other very
quickly
and indeed no matter what the expansion
rate is you can get so far apart that
these things will be receding from each
other faster than light but it's not
that they're moving they're not moving
through the universe faster than light
it's the universe it's just stretching
rather sedately
so if the universe is a medium
then they're not traveling through the
medium the medium itself is doing the
moving and they're just kind of sitting
there along for the ride
yes yes so they they
literally ride along
with the with the stretch of the
universe okay
moving volume but just to be clear
astrophysically they could be
moving on their own they could be
orbiting other galaxies and things like
that they could have their own motion
but that motion itself is not
it's in the fabric of the universe and
the expansion of the universe is is a
level above that right oh but when you
get so so for example andromeda the
galaxy is coming towards us so not
everything's moving above everything
else because it's close enough
that the gravitational interaction
between the milky way andromeda
completely overwhelms the stretch but if
you go out to large enough distances
then
that the stretch wins and everything
flies apart from everything else but
neil said that they can be they as you
said they can be absolutely stationary
in
in the fabric of the universe i mean
it's kind of you've got to be careful
with these these are models right and
these are pictures um if you so if you
look at what einstein's
equations tell you they don't they just
tell you you've got points and you can
define some distance between them and
you can see how that
distance changes and that's it really
well yes that's the point it's not
there's nothing
strange about the fact that things can
receive from each other faster than the
speed of light that just is a property
of something that just stretches
with things in it
okay well keep going the more things in
this list because i think the i think
the questioner
has a point
where here we are saying there's nothing
the speed of light is the limit and now
we're saying no that space can stretch
faster than the speed line we have
quantum entanglement which moves faster
than light and tunneling is faster than
light all of this so maybe we should
stop saying nothing moves faster than
light well so you you can certainly say
that information
doesn't travel faster than the speed of
blight between two places
or two events whatever you want to call
them quantum entanglement is a great
thing it for those of you that
don't know what it is it's give us a
give us a minute on that yeah for sure
so you can imagine i always describe it
in terms of quantum coins right so you
can have these you have a quantum coin
which is a heads 50 of the time when you
look at it entails 50 at the time when
you look at it
but the key weird thing about quantum
mechanics is that uh
it will not be heads or tails
until you look at it and we can have a
huge philosophical discussion about what
that means and there's a whole
literature on it but just that's the way
that nature behaves right
so the the coin can be by the way just
to be clear brian just because we don't
want to like mislead people here
it has nothing to do with your eye brain
connection
right it's not it's not that you look at
is that if you make a measurement of it
no matter what's making the measurement
right 100 correct
it's nothing to do with your
consciousness
or anything else okay
so
it's an entangled state of two quantum
coins and i do this to my live show
actually i write it down you can have a
pair of quantum coins and they can be in
the state heads tails
plus tails heads
heads tails plus sails heads so that's
what they are
if you look at them
right with the caveat you said if
they're
then
they could be heads tails or tails heads
never heads head over tails they're
always
all they're always all those things
they're always heads of tails
well and then but then in the so-called
copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics if you look at them then they
will then become if you look at them
with the caveat neil said they've got to
be careful with language then they will
be in one or other of those
configurations wow the key thing about
entanglement is you can separate that
those coins then
but they're still in that entangled
state you're very careful about it and
we've done this quantum computers work
like this right so you separate them
they're still in their entangled state
and then as the question is said it is
true
they then
make an observation of one of them then
then
then and it turns out it's heads
even if it's a billion light years away
the other one's then tails
because that was the state it was set up
with if that one's heads that one's
tails and that one tells that one so
that that's quantum entanglement in a
nutshell and it is indeed einstein
called its spooky action at a distance
he didn't like it at all so there is
however however the really important
thing to say is you can't signal using
that process even though you might
intuitively think i could send morse
code or something i could send dots and
dashes i could say yes or no
immediately across the universe i could
answer a question yes or no
you can't with that it's really
built into the structure of the theory
so even if you might think that
that the spirit of relativity is being
broken the letter of the law is not
because information doesn't travel
faster than speed of light in that sense
so what about all this talk about the
future of entanglement possibly
uh being
the foundation for
uh
for encryption
oh yeah so the this is it's often
described if you think about that
entangled system
it's a very rich system it's much richer
than just two bits they call qubits
these things
you you gave the simple you gave the
simplest possible case yeah yeah and so
it's a generally you can entangle things
photons for example and or electrons you
can entangle them um and the point is
that the the structure the information
potential if you like is much richer
it's often entanglements often in
quantum computing is called an
information resource right so you're
right so you can do things with this you
can build very powerful computers
they're very good at certain things at
the moment one of which is breaking
encryption right they're extremely good
at factorizing large numbers which is
what our banking is built on so yes uh
so you so that they are part of our
technology now this property of the
universe is part of our technical by the
way chuck do you know who has the world
record for
most distant entangled particles in the
world no
china
someone asked me that the other day and
i couldn't i didn't know how what the
distance is i know people have done it
over there oh so they've done it from
earth to orbit and china did it so it's
it's earth orbit distance and they've
also done it in fiber optics which i
think is harder right because it's not
just open air so to speak
and there could be more
ways to break
the entanglement in preventing the great
distances so unless i saw there's 50
kilometers
entangled via fiber optics which means
this can work across a city
scale
for example that's amazing
but i'll tell you how um it's a very
good question because how how difficult
it is to understand really fundamentally
there's a leonard suskind he's one of
the great um black hole theorists a
great theoretical physicist people wrote
by the way a brilliant book called the
theoretical minimum if you're really
interested in quantum mechanics and you
really want to get down into it his book
theoretical minimum i've got mechanics
superb and isn't he the guy who's like
a big exponent of the holographic
universe too yes uh he invented that
really with geraldo but he um has got
be came up with the theory which he
works on called er equals epar so epr is
really the entanglement it's einstein
pedolsky and rosen so they in in the 30s
i think it was einstein with these two
colleagues did a lot of work on
entanglement really trying to understand
it and see what it meant for reality and
er is einstein rosen which is wormholes
so there is a picture of the quantum
entanglement which has come to the
surface in trying to understand black
holes that you can picture these things
being separated by as i said light years
these quantum coins or whatever you want
to call them being linked with the
wormhole
which links them together and so that's
very a very kind of cutting-edge
advanced way of looking at it which is
not
all together widely accepted but a
mainstream in the study of black holes
and how information gets out of like
well but at least that feels better
than this happening in the middle of
empty space right i mean if you connect
them with a wormhole however exotic that
is
i can feel that all right i'm with you
on that all right and then the structure
of the universe is all uh connected by
wormholes
pairing up
entangled entities what we're looking at
is something called emergent spacetime
which is very cutting-edge sean carroll
actually you will know wrote a good book
on this thing's called something deeply
hidden sean called a physicist at cal
tech i think he's uh he's moved recently
is that correct
yeah
but but so this idea is that space-time
emerges from quantum entanglement so i
think it's true to say the general view
now uh in the course of the cutting edge
is that entanglement and space and time
are intimately linked
so you're losing me on i know i don't i
don't want to take up the show because
now i'm lost on the
i am lost
on this entanglement entanglement and
the black holes because you're talking
about
you know what she says in the question
here is you know you're talking about
spaghettification
it's reduced to a stream of atoms and
then you were talking about the
information coming out so
maybe i'm too sci-fi in this
reconstruction of this information how
do you do that without losing all the
information if you come down to the
atoms themselves get broken apart i'm i
don't understand how that would actually
that entanglement would then be anything
um on on the side of reconstitution what
would it be it's it would just be a big
mess it's a brilliant question and um
yeah oh my god it is
see
chuck is about to pop right there
don't be don't be afraid not to know
what the people are talking about
because you might end up asking a
brilliant question
but where we act brian we got to take a
break okay uh when we come back we'll
pick up and see if all of chuck's
gaskets were blown
all right we'll be we'll be right back
with cosmic queries with brian cox just
blowing our mind as as as he as he can
do on star talk
we're back the third and final segment
star talk cosmic queries brian cox
uh a physicist extraordinaire just
helping us
decode the universe one particle at a
time
and chuck if you were with us chuck blew
a gasket at the end there
trying to understand what happens if
particles go in a black hole does the
black hole remember what the thing was
and if the information comes out again
does it remember and if information is
what's moving through the uh wormholes
given the fabric of the universe
brian you're messing with us
it's been around since the 1980s
based on stephen hawking's very famous
paper in 1974 which showed that
black holes radiate black holes ain't so
black steven said they they radiate they
glow like coals in the sky called
hawking radiation and ultimately because
they glow
like coals in the sky and it's to do
actually with entanglement quantum
entanglement in the vacuum of space and
the event horizon of the black hole and
so anyway they evaporate
they're gone then one day they are gone
and it's now widely accepted that
all the information that fell into the
black hole over time
including the star that built it the
whole lot ends up imprinted heavily
scrambled as chuck said really scrambled
up and imprinted in the hawking
radiation that came out so if you were
and this is very much in principle right
if you were
on almost omniscient super being with
the world the biggest quantum computer
you could possibly imagine and you
managed to stick all the information all
the whole communications into the
quantum computer then in principle you
could reconstruct what happened over all
that time
so this is gluing back together a
shredded document
right um then in principle
if you could gather everything that came
off the book you could reconstruct the
book so and we think fundamentally in
physics physics is deterministic this is
what determinism is information is not
destroyed it's scrambled up
unimaginably difficult to reconstruct
things but in fundamentally in principle
we think that information is conserved
in the universe the black holes appeared
to violate that
because it appeared that stuff that fell
in never came out all right now wait a
minute now now i got to get okay
i'm so sorry man because i just i can't
go through without just knowing this
because neil and i on a show during an
explainer give me a second we talked
about black holes
and then we were talking about
virtual particles that appear outside of
the black hole
is that indeed information from within
the black hole that's the picture that
we have oh snap
well well well i think chuck the way to
think about it is it came out of the
energy
of the gravitational energy
that is the field that the black hole
makes so it kind of doesn't matter in
that case
whether it's on one side of the event
horizon or the other
am i right here brian i mean it's just
it's the it's the black hole
giving there's lots of ways to think
about it i mean
stephen's paper actually the 1974 one
stephen stephen's paper
not joey's paper not jimmy's paper but
yeah stevie reno's paper okay
go on brian empty space is heavily
entangled
and he and he says this is not it's an
introduction it's not the best it's not
an
exact picture but it's good enough right
so you can imagine these particles pop
in and out of existence all the time in
the vacuum of space and they're
entangled right and in and out in and
out of that
and if you think on the when there's an
event horizon of a black hole
you can have this situation where one of
them is on the inside and one of them is
on the outside you shouldn't think of
them crossing the horizon you just
you can have this situation or
whatever's inside one of them is outside
they're entangled
the one that's outside can go away and
take energy away from the black hole as
neil said uh and the the one inside you
would
think just stays there and it eventually
goes to the singularity or whatever's
happening
um
but but because the black hole
evaporates
then it's gone one day then the thing
that this was entangled with the one
that went out into the universe has gone
so that's the destruction of information
and that that's the heart of the
information paradox so it's a different
way of producing
radiation if you burn the book
then it's everything's in contact with
it itself and you know every it's all
you know how these
how the smoke and the ashes are being
produced right but it's different the
way that a black hole glows and so that
would cause a problem
well wait so so is so is it still
entangled with the particle that escaped
is the particle inside the event horizon
still entangled with the particle that
escaped so the problem and actually the
problem actually comes about halfway
through the black cole's life it's
called the page time for the exercise
but broadly you can think of it as
saying these things are entangled i
can't just destroy entanglement because
if i do that i destroy information and
in some sense destroy space as well it's
often referred to as the glue that holds
space together but it's you can't just
erase entanglement but then if you've
got all these hawking radiation
particles emitted for trillions of years
that are all entangled with the interior
of the black hole and then the black
hole is gone
then you have a problem so that's the
black hole information
problem so so
again getting back to the point of the
speed of light these
um
you're inventing or you and and and and
partners in crime here are inventing
wormholes
as the medium between the two no
actually interestingly historically yes
uh
leonard siskind and others had this
picture this er equals epr picture that
i described but actually the um the
modern picture uh is is
they're not being invented it's it's
often described as as gravity itself it
seems that einstein's theory general
relativity kind of knows more than you
give it credit for
so so you get these geometries these
shapes of space time
that are really
they're emerging from the theory it's
that you don't put them in by hand
so because it sounds like someone's just
fudged it right just made it made up
something and gone ah let's just have
wormholes all over the place that's
really not how it's happening in the
calculations people are doing
calculations and then it's beginning to
look like
there are wormholes backing up this
speculative idea that was uh offered a
few decades ago now so that's that's the
way it's going
so so what you know what what blows my
mind is the idea that
things we just accepted blindly as
that's just how it is
and when you accept something as how it
is you no longer ask a deeper question
and you just content with all that it's
curved space because you know matter
curve space space tells matter how to
move and we're done here on to the next
problem and you kept thinking about it i
love you and your people i i should say
it was it was initially
that was use take credit they're not
here brian they're not here just take
the credit they're not here who cares
you know sometimes we tell these stories
in physics don't we we glorify people
when we put them on pedestal but it is
widely said that
that stephen hawking initially asked
this question so he really pushed it and
said my calculation from 1974 suggests
that black holes destroy information and
he really pushed it
and people like leonard suskind
and jared tahoeft initially was a nobel
prize winner really pushed back against
it and that was the beginning of this
field in the 80s but you're right it's
it's people just not saying oh it
doesn't matter it's
it's a fundamental clash of principle
between quantum mechanics and general
relativity that's the value in it and
just to be clear when scientists
disagree that that is an amazing that's
a fun fact because something's go
something's going to break something's
going to be discovered some new data is
going to reveal intellectual cage man
smackdown
works on it from the initial
moment that this you dream of
discovering a fundamental problem with
your world because you know neil
that's that's where it gets exciting you
gotta i was wrong you know there's
something wrong here
so do you okay here's a question for
both of you then do you
as a scientist think that
when someone comes up and
disproves something or
uh proves something else one or the
other that
your
wrong supposition made that happen is it
like everybody gets to take credit or
because
well i'll i'll take that first so i want
to get brian's reaction to that um it's
possible to be
interesting and wrong
okay rather than uninteresting and wrong
all right so the geocentric universe
with earth in the middle that was
interestingly wrong all right they were
trying to fit things and that had a lot
of intellectual capital invested in
trying to understand it but it it posed
the problem that attracted people's
interests and so anytime we talk about
copernicus we also talk about ptolemy
right he's in he's in the conversation
here so
so so brian
people who who you have to stand on
their shoulders even to say they're
wrong absolutely um the
i mean as i said steven hawking
initially um he had a bet with them it
was john prescott who's a quantum very
famous quantum information physicist and
our physicist who works on black hole
they're the best and hawking bet the
information was destroyed in black hole
evaporation
uh he then conceded
after some work via maldacena actually
another he conceded this is the
holographic stuff he mentioned
holography didn't he came from
holography this so he conceded and said
i was wrong and he was delighted he
changed his mind and the bet was
that he had to give john fresco some
encyclopedias so the other bets on
encyclopedias john being american
wanted baseball encyclopedias and steven
was going to get cricket encyclopedias
in the last edition of a brief history
of time that stephen added to there's a
great story at the end where he said it
so he he gave he had to give john
prescott the baseball encyclopedia and
he says in brief his fifth time given
what we've just discussed about you know
the things and the ashes and the smoke
and all the information he said i should
have given them in an urn and burnt them
and then
because all the information would have
oh my gosh
the ashes of the encyclopedia
first of all stephen hawking's great
humor because he was extremely funny
but secondly it shows how delighted he
was delighted to have to change his mind
uh we you know after on a position that
he'd held for decades actually
i would add that reporters writing about
scientists and people there's this sort
of belief out there that we all
just want to agree with each other right
and don't want to rock the boat they
talk about a person's cherished theories
they don't want to give it up and the
best of the scientists would just as
soon have it go away if it's replaced by
something amazing and let me tell you
this brian if i want to bet
that was that fundamental about the
operations of the universe
i would have come up with something a
little more interesting than
encyclopedia i'm sorry all of them
as well they all
engage in ridiculous steps
and the point is that you said that the
the reason they did they do that but all
this community of people do it is
because you don't want to be right you
just want to understand
nature it doesn't
no one cares about you wow
you know what i i say that to my wife
every argument
what are you talking about
all right quick you know we have like
one minute left i can't believe we only
did three questions this whole show
so chuck let's see if brian has like
sound bites in him one more question
here's a great one and this is uh george
rottier who says hello dr tyson dr cox
and lord nice which is greater the
number of hypothetical plank length
objects stacked in a six foot tall human
being or the number of six foot tall
humans stat head to toe in the largest
star we've ever discovered
[Laughter]
it's that yeah planck's gonna no matter
what he didn't even have
in the universe then it would be the
number of humans because there's a
finite number of plant lengths in a
human and there's
quite possibly an infinite number of
humans you could stack
in well like the observable universe
it's a good question now that might be
the problem
yes
there's an edge to it three billion
light years
uh
out to the horizon
then how many uh six feet what's 43
billion like years divided by
that
george george i got i got to tell you
george george if you're listening i got
to tell you you did it you finally see
what it takes to get two scientists
to just go off in a tangent
like i mean my answer would have been
bro stop smoking so much weed that would
have been my answer
and you two were sitting there just like
well you know the universe does have an
edge okay
43 billion light years exactly
[Music]
so brian take us out with your best
attempt to get people to appreciate how
small a plank length is yeah there you
go take us out with that um i i haven't
got the numbers on top of my head i i
should know how many plank lengths cross
a proton i do know that and i've
forgotten it
i've forgotten it
oh
silly little information like that just
seems to slip right out on i absolutely
know it because i've just written it
i've written a book on it
[Laughter]
okay that's okay what happened check
that means in this show we just drain
brian yes of all available knowledge and
he's this he's this pile of
weeping goo on the other side
minus 35. okay 10 to the minus 35 meters
isn't it right it's 10 to the minus 35
that's point number nine thirty five
miles
so um so so if you wanted a meter if
you're in a meter this is right ten ten
meters there'd be a million million
million million million
million blank legs that's right isn't it
yes center hour supposed by 10 to the
36. so there you go
so we've got a million million million
million million plank lengths in one
meter that's about right
it's about one and a half that whatever
something like that one once you start
using exponents i'm i know that i don't
understand the number yeah i know i
can't conceive of it at that point it's
like what would a difference give me a
distance
we will leave oh and one i'll leave you
with one thing here that plank length
is basically the
the digital
structure of the fabric of the universe
itself is that fair is that is that like
a pixel massive discovery in black hole
physics made by jacob beckenstein back
in the 1970s is that if you if you say
how much information can a black hole
store it's called the entropy of the
black hole and then it's the area
of the event horizon in square plank
lengths
that's that does look like space is
related in that sense yeah all right
dudes we got to end it there so brian i
i i know you on twitter is professor
brian cox uh what what what are you on
facebook and every everywhere else
um facebook uh something like that yeah
i don't really do much
i think my twitter copied into facebook
actually more facebook because i think
you know twitter yeah okay you got it
people shouting small small sentences
it's a cesspool it's accessible yeah all
right and chuck we can find you chuck
nice comic yes
i'm gonna change it to black max planck
we'll see we'll see tell me how that
goes
all right guys
we're done here we are so done here uh
this has been star talk uh cosmic
queries edition uh with one of our
favorite guests brian cox
always good to have you brian chuck as
always neil degrasse tyson here your
personal astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
you